[Music]
hmm
ladies and gentlemen
this
is the 2014 xbox global media briefing
please welcome the head of xbox
phil
spencer
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone and welcome to e3
it's an honor to be with you today
let me start by welcoming the fans here
with us in los angeles and the millions
of fans watching us around the world on
the web on xbox live and on spike tv
i'd also like to recognize the
developers here with us today
developers working to bring their
creations to life and deliver them to
the world
this week
we share a common purpose with our
friends at sony nintendo and the
developers and publishers in our
industry
that purpose is to showcase the passion
creativity and potential behind the
fastest growing form of entertainment in
the world games
and we're here together at an incredible
time in our industry with the launch of
two new consoles in the last year this
generation is off to the hottest start
in history
this renewed interest and excitement
benefits everyone creators publishers
console manufacturers and especially
gamers
on behalf of the entire xbox team i want
to personally thank you the millions of
xbox one owners around the world
we've been humbled and amazed by all of
your comments ideas tweets
but most importantly your support
your feedback showed up in the console
we launched in november
and in the monthly updates we've
delivered since
you are shaping the future of xbox and
we are better for it
today we're dedicating our entire
briefing to games
our goal is to make xbox one the best
place to play games this generation
first i want to show some of the great
games coming to xbox one in 2014 and
later in the show we'll announce some of
the new games coming to xbox in the
future the lineup is diverse huge
franchises new ip independent games and
maybe a few of my old favorites
gamers are helping set the future
direction of xbox
and our friends at activision and
sledgehammer games are doing the exact
same thing with the best selling
franchise in xbox history
from the first time i saw what
sledgehammer games was working on i was
truly inspired in every sense this game
raises the bar for the next generation
i'm proud to open our show with what i
believe is the beginning of a new era
for this franchise
and once again i have good news
xbox owners will be the first to play
all of the add-on content
here's the first look
at call of duty advanced warfare on xbox
one
[Applause]
hey
see you on the other side
trajectory
now
resetting drop points
you still in one piece
nature
get the door
[Music]
okay
we need to get our feet on the ground
and link up the demo team one yes sir
contact contact
got a sheer drop on this side
there's a clear spot over here you'll
have to jump down
everyone get your boosters ready
remember short first
everyone up i think so
[Applause]
we are tracking a drawn swarm heading
your way copy that
everyone keep your eyes open
oh
down
[Music]
that launcher is heavily armored you're
gonna have to find an access panel and
plant the charges inside it
right
contact
damn i see my arms
lift it up you gotta go now
mitchell we're out of time you gotta
jump now
it's okay
let's see on the other side
[Music]
rachel
mitchell
thanks man glad you two is down i need
immediate medivac
hold on
stay with me
you're gonna be all right
we're gonna get you home
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from turn 10
studios dan greenawalt
[Music]
at turn 10 we are inspired by your
passion for cars and racing
right now
every week almost a million of you are
playing in the forza universe
thank you racing fans
12 years ago we started with a mission
to ignite gaming passion in car lovers
and car passion in gamers
to do this we've delivered unique
experiences
like community paint sharing and
drivetar opponents powered by xbox live
we've premiered amazing dream cars like
the mclaren p1 and the la ferrari
we've continually updated our game and
added new free content like road america
and long beach for our fans
and for you
may i present the most iconic sports car
track in the world
the nurburgring
jackie stewart's green hell will be
making its next-gen debut in forza
motorsport 5. including the full 16 mile
combined circuit it's been 100 captured
at millimeter accuracy and crafted from
the ground up for this generation
we're committed to creating your home
for racing on xbox one
so we're thrilled to announce that the
nurburgring will be available starting
today
and that's for everyone with forza
motorsport 5
and it's free
and now we're excited to show you the
next edition of the forza franchise to
present forza horizon 2 on xbox one
please welcome playground games ralph
fulton
[Music]
thanks dan
and thank you forza fans
horizon 2 is an action-packed open-world
driving game filled with incredible
vistas amazing music
and over 200 of the world's greatest
cars
including the premiere of the
lamborghini huracan our car list is
bigger
and more diverse than ever
built for xbox one on forza motorsport
5's graphics engine horizon 2 delivers a
full day night cycle
and introduces dynamic weather
all in stunning 1080p
last year forza's drivatar technology
changed racing forever
now evolved for your open world your
four-to-five drivatar is already playing
in forza horizon 2.
when you choose to play on xbox live
dedicated servers allow you to join
instantly
no lobbies no waiting
and the experience is even more social
when you create a club with up to 1 000
members your club can become a community
in its own right
forza horizon 2 is epic it's fun
it's beautiful and it's socially
connected the road trip of your life
begins exclusively on xbox
this september 30th
[Applause]
[Music]
i got a love that keeps on fighting
is
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's here
[Music]
do
[Applause]
please welcome senior producer from
ubisoft vincent pompeon
[Music]
hello everyone i'm here to introduce
assassin's creed unity the first
exclusively next generation installment
in our epic saga
unity is set in 18th century paris
during the chaotic and ruthless period
of the french revolution
as assassin arnold victor dorian you
will explore our biggest playground ever
which we have filled with hundreds of
quests activities and rewards
but that's not all
acu also marks the first time you will
be able to form your own brotherhood and
join with up to three friends on xbox
live
let's
let's jump in this exclusive gameplay
demo to show you how unity completely
redefines the assassin's creed
experience
enjoy
[Music]
hey somebody help me
is stealing
[Applause]
is
[Music]
cities
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
get up
said keep those dogs out of the
courtyard
take care of this or i will use your
head as a piss pot
you men secure the foot gates
first one that brings me ahead gets 50
soon you heard me
[Music]
need to hold the rear jacks
get the horses
i don't know
[Music]
thank you all for coming
despite the poor sports outside
our illustrious host the marquis wishes
to assure you that the rabble outside
can cause us
return time
now
[Music]
cowards get back here
we can work together spare me please
they're only peasants
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
the very first game that i played was
missile command in the arcade and i was
completely blown away by it space
invaders i remember the early scott
adams adventure games on my ti-994a
it was mind-blowing to see that somebody
could control what was going on a screen
my dad brought home a sears pong station
for our television with a little twist
controller and a button i don't know
what year it was but it was pizza hut
and it was uh space invaders
and i got hooked
[Music]
let those who would destroy us
step into the light
[Music]
the world is tearing itself apart
chaos has left its mark upon me
[Music]
i am hunted for the power i wield
you will break
i will die first
[Applause]
[Music]
cover mechanic right
oh
[Music]
you
and your crate are safe now
[Music]
oh hey
welcome to spectacular
sunset city
okay
here's the situation a contaminated
energy drink has turned everyone into
mutants
there are survivors doing whatever they
can to get by
but some of them are dicks attacking
others for their stuff
just ignore that one
but it's not all bad all this place
needs is a hero one who doesn't just
survive but does it
this style
who is this hero
me not not me oh you
can't you survive the many dangers can
you help others survive can you save
sunset city can you
for the love of god can you
of course you can
it's a [__] video game
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from insomniac
games
ted price
[Music]
in sunset overdrive
you
yes you are the hero
customize your character be who you want
to be traverse the open world with speed
strategy and style using an arsenal of
unconventional weapons and special
abilities to save sunset city
now in this demo two of the game's
factions have overrun the local
amusement park and our mission is to
fight our way to the roller coaster on
the far side
let's go
i used to think this town was boring
yes
[Music]
that's
let's right this
nice
[Music]
clean up
okay this is gonna be fun
uh
see my name
[Music]
now it's not just about the campaign
we've also got a big eight player
experience called chaos squad on
dedicated servers powered by xbox live
eight friends cooperatively earn loot
and save sunset city so whether you're
playing solo or with friends be the hero
you want to be in sunset overdrive
starting october 28th exclusively on
xbox one thank you
here comes a new challenger
[Music]
all the dead rising heroes are back and
kicking it old school in an all new dead
rising 3 arcade adventure
[Music]
as your favorite capcom characters go
with up to four players online
it's game time
[Music]
bonus stages
they're all super special surprises for
the capcom 31st anniversary
[Music]
downright fierce
super ultra dead rising three arcade
remix hyper edition ex
alpha
tofu
nice available soon actually sooner than
soon it's available now
[Applause]
[Music]
please welcome the founder and ceo of
harmonix alex fergopolis
[Applause]
since we released the first dance
central back in 2010
fans have danced to over 220 million
songs
and for the past four years harmonix has
been delivering high quality innovative
motion gaming experiences for connect
on october 21st we're excited to release
disney fantasia music evolved for xbox
360 and xbox one
in this game we've created a world where
music and magic are one where you'll
become a sorcerer's apprentice and remix
your favorite songs through expressive
motion game play but since the launch
of the xbox one our fans have been
asking us when are you bringing back our
favorite dance franchise
well the wait ends this september with
dance central spotlight an all
digital only title available exclusively
for download on xbox one
with a soundtrack of chart-topping hits
and new technology that allows us to get
new tracks into the game much faster
than ever before you'll be dancing to
the hottest hits of the moment week
after week
so
dance to top hits and dance central
spotlight and explore a world of music
and magic with disney fantasia music
evolved only on xbox this fall
see you at e3
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks and good morning for the last two
years the team at lionhead has been
building a new kind of role-playing
experience
fable legends is a bold and innovative
adventure and i'm proud to share it with
you here today
welcome to a place of magic fairy tale
and myth
this is where we can discover the
stories and characters of albion this is
bright lodge the social heart of fable
legends and your home in the game
say hello to sterling he's a classic
fable character
enter hero brave noble capable of self
narration
in this growing town you and your
friends find and begin your quest you'll
also encounter many of the heroes you'll
team up with here are just a few of them
winter a hero of will
somewhere out there is treasure
adventure
and a world of things better than
standing right here
rook a hero of skill
all right fancy pants
and inga a hero of strength well don't
hang about polishing your kodkins we've
got questing to do
right let's see what's out there
in this chapter of fable legend's story
the heroes enter an old and overgrown
ruin in order to recover an ancient
artifact
while humanity and its champions venture
into untamed lands in primeval forests
the natural world prepares to strike
back
magical beasts monsters and even nastier
creatures are marshaling their forces to
defeat those who dare trespass into
their realm
we get in we get out swift and smooth
family motto and lifestyle choice old
chap shut up stay electric
red caps
stay behind me
all right boys and girls this is where
it gets serious
this quest shall lead me to honor glory
and oh
treasure
i'll be taking this darling over here
you like ice with that
ah if only there had been more of them
touch wood and scratch your word when we
got away with that one
our vision is for more than just a
cooperative fable we want to create an
experience unique in multiplayer gaming
something innovative and something
dramatic we needed a new challenge for
you our players in fable legends you can
be the villain
the villain player in fable legends
brings a whole new perspective to the
game controlling the world from above
like a malevolent god
every creature every trap and every
spell you've seen so far every challenge
our heroes are about to face the villain
orchestrates it all
if you're the villain it's your job to
do the worst you decide how where and
who to target with your many evil powers
and tricks
how does our story end
the outcome of each of your adventures
depends on what's stronger is it the
bravery and teamwork of the four heroes
or the skill and dastardly cunning of
the villain stand ready now
you want me
you got me
[Music]
we're almost there stick with it
watch yourselves
[Music]
get back get back
i think i chose the wrong underwear for
this one
[Music]
the bigger they are the easier the
targets
oh crap
on behalf of the team at lionhead it's
been my pleasure to share this first
look into fable legends our multiplayer
beta will begin this fall to sign up and
learn more visit fablelegends.com join
us in our magical world and play as a
part of a team of heroes or mastermind
the game as the evil villain the choice
is yours
[Applause]
if i could mash any two games i just
feel like all of them yeah just put them
all in one i just want like grand theft
auto but i could be a ninja turtle and
batman together ninja turtles and batman
actually no that's what i want just
ninja turtles and batman yeah yeah the
arcade ninja turtles we're coming april
like they look like that yeah
everybody's inside right
in the style of the arkham series of
batman yeah that's what i want
[Music]
wow
really
where's the rest of your game oh i
almost forgot the best part
[Music]
this up last night
okay
not bad
but wait till you see my game
welcome to desert of death i see desert
but i don't see any
right
[Music]
that was awesome i told you so what
should our next game be steve's building
some new hacks nice how about zombie max
yes zombie mex from space
done game on
[Music]
so
i couldn't with this
[Music]
wow
almost 10 years without a new game guess
we'll have to make our own
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
if i were to go hang out with somebody
from a video game i'd probably choose
duke nukem and the old duke like
original duke and hang out with marcus
the first character you play in state of
decay because
he's just an everyman he's just a dude
the main character in limbo the ogre and
titanfall the guy's walking down
manhattan with his little buddy
i'd do that down the streets of seattle
that would be pretty cool be master
chief he's just one of the best
characters best design characters great
background great story everything about
him is just awesome
[Music]
more
to find him
you have to forget the stories
forget the legends
you have to do more than walk in his
footsteps
for he is more than the sum of his
actions
i tell you this
not because i trust you agent
but because all our lives are at stake
[Music]
because the seeds of our future
are sown in his past
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen from 343 industries
bonnie ross
at the end of halo 4 master chief was
mourning the loss of his closest
companion
he was questioning everything his role
his purpose and who and what he was
fighting for
now master chief begins a deeply
personal journey
questioning authority and searching for
the truth
and as we just revealed there's also
someone else looking for answers
searching for him
this is about master chief's journey his
past and his future
at 343 when we think about the halo
universe
we think of it as a real place inhabited
by real characters and populated with
the real almost tangible history and so
bringing that history to life on xbox
one isn't just about making a game
it's about embracing our traditions and
our roots and everything that we are
passionate about with halo it's about
retelling chief's entire legendary tale
precisely the way you remembered it and
then also from a new perspective as we
lead up to the launch of halo 5
guardians next year
and so on november 11
for the first time ever you can play the
entire
master chief saga on a single console
the xbox one with halo the master chief
collection
[Applause]
i love you too
the master chief collection is massive
it includes the game's halo combat
evolved halo 2 halo 3 and halo 4.
but it's not just a celebration of our
past it's also about laying the
foundation for our future
everything you're about to see today is
included in the master chief collection
i'd like to welcome dan ayub 343's
executive producer of the master chief
collection
[Music]
thanks bonnie
when we started working on the master
chief collection we knew we had an
opportunity to do something special
to not only rekindle our fans memories
but to also introduce a new generation
of fans to the halo universe
the collection features features a
single unified interface to give you all
four games with everything unlocked on
one disc in a single seamless interface
so you can play the chief's journey
however you want
now unlocking everything at the offset
also lets us do something else we're
going to create custom playlists taking
great moments from all four games and
combining them together
yeah it's pretty cool
now as many of you know
november marks the 10-year anniversary
of halo 2.
and i am excited to tell you that halo 2
is getting the full anniversary
treatment we've retouched
we've retouched every part of the game
and of course you can switch from new to
classic at the touch of a button
now halo 2's multiplayer was special for
a lot of reasons and we wanted to keep
that intact so halo 2 anniversary will
contain the original halo 2 multiplayer
exactly as it shipped 10 years ago
in addition we selected six iconic halo
2 maps to recreate with the power of the
xbox one
i'd like to show you guys some gameplay
on ascension with the help of our pro
players today
okay guys everyone ready
all right
okay let's go
so we're going to be showing you
gameplay from ghost pov because he's a
lot better than i am
oh yes we are playing spartans versus
elise
a knight and he's approaching on me okay
thank you
uh you also saw there a dual wield
another big mainstay
of halo 2 gameplay and as i said we are
playing spartans versus elites
this is actually one of my favorite maps
got some great sight lines you can
really see the vistas popping here as
well
nice
okay oh
get the banshee
okay here we go we got him
we got him
oh you're yeah i got you
there you have it
that's just a sneak peek of what's
coming your way november 11th the master
chief collection has over 100
multiplayer maps that is every map ever
released on halo one through four
all running on their original engines
all running at 1080p 60 frames per
second on dedicated servers
and finally because achievements are
awesome the master chief collection will
ship with 4 000 gamer score
thanks bonnie thank you stan
that's a huge amount of game play but in
addition to great game play we wanted to
lay the foundation for the future
so included in the master chief
collection is halo nightfall our
live-action digital series created in
collaboration with executive producer
ridley scott and director sergio mimika
gazon
the series introduces a pivotal new
character in a story that leads right up
to halo 5 guardians and as you can see
halo nightfall is currently in
production and we're thrilled to have
this opportunity to work with such an
amazingly talented team
and last but not least the final piece
of the master chief collection this
december we bring you the halo 5
guardians beta
it's a celebration of our arena
multiplayer legacy and the beta will
debut new game modes and features
so here's just a small taste of what
you're going to experience this holiday
enjoy
ready let's move
[Music]
so
me
please welcome back phil spencer
[Music]
the halo franchise is the reason xbox is
here today
halo launched the original xbox halo
launched xbox live and halo was a
cornerstone on xbox 360. now the master
chief collection will allow gamers to
experience the entire master chief story
only on xbox one
you'll be able to play everything you've
just seen on xbox one this holiday
these games represent just a handful of
the many games you will see this year
in addition to our holiday lineup we are
also investing in new ip familiar
franchises and continued investment in
xbox live
i'm excited to share a selection of our
games from our 2015 portfolio and beyond
i believe these games highlight the
breadth depth and diversity of our
gaming portfolio
let's start with the game from an
incredible studio
their first game
was one of my favorite games of all time
it debuted on xbox 360 and went on to
win game of the year honors
this is a first look at what they have
been working on for the last four years
and it will debut on xbox in early 2015.
so
right
[Music]
uh
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
director of id at xbox chris charla
hey everybody
id at xbox is a program we've built to
help independent developers realize
their creative visions and bring great
games to xbox one
independent developers like cappy iron
galaxy and team colorblind build some of
the most unique and diverse gameplay
experiences anywhere
through the id and xbox program we're
supporting their creativity by providing
developers with free development kits
free middleware options and ongoing
support that enables developers to
self-publish on xbox one
they get to use the full power and
unique features of xbox from live to
connect smart glass our impulse triggers
and of course our support for eight
controllers and one xbox
we're thrilled to have so many amazing
creators working on incredible new games
many of which are going to ship first
for console on xbox one
games that feature innovative
multiplayer like lovers in a dangerous
spacetime by asteroid base
totally new takes on social play like
hashtag idarb from other ocean or that
are just rad games like play gank
evolved from endemic creations
cuphead from studio mdhr and massive
chalice from double fine
let's take a look at just a fraction of
the hundreds of exciting new games from
independent developers that are coming
soon to xbox one
[Music]
um
knows
[Applause]
[Music]
i think
is
[Music]
my favorite game of all time is the nba
2k series i'll never know how to dunk in
real life but as lebron james i can do
it and i've been doing it for 15 years
kamel nanjiani i've been duncan for 15
years yeah my favorite game of all time
would be operation flashpoint it sort of
like was less of like a call of duty
like first person shooter crazy and more
of like a like a military simulator i'm
a big simulator guy lots of like flight
simulators il-2 stermovic
what a game the crowd is going nuts
right here yeah at the galen center
when you're ready open your eyes
i think we're making progress in these
sessions
you say the flashbacks have stopped
this is excellent improvement but i'm
concerned that you're still shutting
yourself away at home
it's important
to gradually take steps into the outside
world
take some walks
maybe pick up a nice hobby
girl your age
we should be exploring new horizons
i'd like to know you're taking care of
yourself
for many people these traumas become a
mental trap
they get
stuck
like a ship frozen in ice
[Music]
there's another type of person
you know what happens to them
miss croft
we become who we're meant to be
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen from cd projekt red
executive producer john mames and conrad
thomas kavitch
hello
conrad and i are totally thrilled to be
able to premiere some new gameplay of
the witcher 3 wild hunt
let's get right into it
so witchers are trained from birth to
find and kill monsters for reward
here we're about 10 hours into the game
on a griffin hunt
the griffin is nearby so we prep for a
possible encounter
probably to adjust its grip on its prey
the items needed for combat in this
instance a set of buffing potions and a
small crossbow
as mutants witchers possess heightened
senses that can be used on command to
among other things track prey we can
better perceive visual and sound clues
in this state
hasn't caught my scent yet
for the bolts we fired
we'll leave a trail of blood behind to
help us track it
this sequence is set in a vast
wilderness area known as no man's land
we can traverse any viewable location in
the world
all the way to the mountain peaks in the
distance and beyond
so we're losing him now so we need to
pick up his tracks again
oh
[Music]
yes
you can come out
damn it
he only came for a brew to break a fever
what are you doing here
dragging a griffin
trail took me through here seems i had a
stroke of luck then thank you
look like deserters could be more bands
in the area
i'll come back once i'm done with the
griffin just in case
fine
happy hunting
monster hunting quests can often
intersect in the open world with points
of interest
so by dispatching those bandits we can
now return to the herbalist later in the
game
now we'll continue on the hunt
let's go
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
this was just a very small part of the
epic rpg that is the witcher 3 wild hunt
thanks for watching thanks to the
zayabista team back in warsaw for their
tremendous effort
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
creative director ken lob
i love e3
i've been making games for about 26
years over 12 here at xbox so i've been
to a lot of shows
basically every show they let me go to
since early 1989.
i like to spend much of my time as
possible helping teams make their games
great
last year we announced killer instinct
one of the games i worked on in my past
i was thrilled with the response of the
show
of course at launch and i'm looking
forward to playing people this week with
tj combo
the idea of rebooting old beloved old
games is something that i have a lot of
passion for
so we're doing it again
there's another game that i've always
wanted to bring back from the original
xbox
some would call it a classic
but i think honestly
design great design is what we should be
looking for when we're deciding what
games we should build
so i'm honored to be up here on the
stage today to announce
well let's just watch the trailer
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
how many hours have you played video
games in your entire in total yeah at
least
30 minutes a day on average 40 hours a
week 52 weeks a year 30 years of playing
games i think it would probably be over
two man years of gaming 36 000
research hours like 60 000
about 15 000 hours over my life not bad
massive hours tens of thousands you're
going for the high score yeah i'm going
big
ladies and gentlemen game director from
massive
ryan barnard
all right
hello everyone it's great to be back
here at e3 this year with microsoft and
xbox
so last year we gave you a glimpse of a
new york city on the brink of collapse
paralyzed by a devastating and deadly
virus
which was released on black friday
and this year we want to take you even
deeper into our world
so let's join a group of division agents
as we navigate through a dangerous part
of the city on our way to establishing a
critical foothold in an area which has
been overrun by hostile factions
[Music]
snow is falling down just a little bit
the world's so quiet and still
santa's out there flying around and it's
true
okay i know where we are
i'm setting the waypoint to the base
check your
map looks like it's pretty close
all right follow me it's this way
looks clear
i'm getting a reading over here
[Music]
this must have been the last train out
looks like everybody panicked
okay where's bronson
i'll send him another invite
this must be where they were talking
about
launch your step
there you are hey guys
i brought chris hey chris hey
open up the area up ahead okay we're
about to unlock my base it's up here on
the right
all right so what do we got here elites
by the base and it's behind the truck
i'm marking them up for you now okay
let's take these guys out first as
quietly as possible all right i have
tesla and pulse up all right ryan let's
change up our skills
i'll pull aggro from the left here
you guys good to go all good yep ready
all right here we go
here's the last guy get the last guy
he's getting away he's gone got incoming
holy crap
there they are there's loads of them
i can't get a shot try and hit him from
the right
i'm gonna switch my weapon okay
i can't move i'm pinned gotta hit him
chris it's all you dude yeah i'm on
it oh god look out let's go let's go
let's go get down
i'm pushing forward i'm pushing forward
hold on
oh there's a guy right behind me
all right you're fine
get up okay last two hit him hit him
down
get this guy on the left
good okay go go we got to move up
forward last one keep the pressure on
somebody do something
good game guys okay
that was good welcome guys
so this is the base of operations
let's try to get medical online first
please welcome game director hideki
kamiya
[Music]
[Applause]
my team and i are excited to present our
next original game exclusively on the
xbox one
as a game creator
my passion has been giving audiences
unique experiences
today
we will give you the first look at our
next creation
prepare to see action at a whole new
scale
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
what's up
ugh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the co-founder and
creative director for cloud gin david
jones
today i'm excited to reveal the return
of a game close to my heart and the
hearts of many gamers
and one we're building all new and
exclusively for xbox one
in addition to a whole new campaign
fully playable in co-op it's also coming
back in a revolutionary new multiplayer
experience
one powered by an army of dedicated
servers on xbox live
it's time to reimagine your open world
gaming experience
this
is the voice of the agency with a
message for vincente villarreal kingpin
of the los muertos gang
compared to your boys in pacific city
you've done very well
[Applause]
you seized a few key districts and the
rest fell like dominoes
[Music]
well you're in luck
we like dominoes
agents
let's play
[Music]
[Applause]
please welcome back phil spencer
[Music]
platinum games and crackdown it's great
to see those games on our stage
yeah crackdown is coming back i said
you'd see crackdown when we had the
right team to build the game that team
is led by the original game creator and
a friend of mine dave jones it was great
to have him on our stage today
today
we showed you 90 minutes of games and
shared our commitment to make xbox one
the best place to play games this
generation
we showed you that this holiday the best
place to play games is on xbox one
but this is just the beginning
we will continue to invest in bringing
new creators to xbox one
we'll continue to bring you new features
to ensure that xbox live is the only
place where you and your friends will be
able to play the most anticipated
multiplayer games of the year
halo call of duty advanced warfare
destiny forza sunset overdrive
battlefield hardline and more
we will continue to listen to you our
community and we'll continue to make
xbox for you
that's not just my personal commitment
but the commitment of the entire xbox
team
thank you for making your voice heard
and thank you for helping us shape the
future of the new xbox
[Music]
um
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you